bonjour et bien la première nouvelle de
cette matinée est une nouvelle tragique
coup de grisou dans une mine du bassin
de lens méricourt à fouquières lez lens
au puits numéro 6 il y aurait 15 morts
et une vingtaine de blessés assez
gravement atteints jeudi il y aurait
parce que on ne connaît pas encore le
chiffre exact qu'il y avait 40 personnes
dans la taille au moment de l'explosion
et comme il se produit des mouvements
pendant le travail on ne peut pas savoir
exactement combien de personnes se
trouvaient sur le lieu même de
l'explosion au moment où cela s'est
produit il faut donc attendre qu'un
pointage fait pour connaître la
situation exacte
l'accident s'est produit vers 9h ce
matin nous avons des envoyés spéciaux
sur place et dès ce soir nous vous
présenterons un premier document sur
cette tragédie il ya eu également un
autre accident ce matin qui a fait 12
morts
quoi 4 à reprendre cette nuit à la base
aéronavale de lann bihoué en bretagne
deux officiers prennent connaissance de
leurs plans de vol mission de routine 14
35 ils montent à bord de leurs neptune
ou les attentes dix hommes d'équipage
les moteurs tournent l'avion se lancent
à 240 km heure il n'arriva pas à prendre
de l'altitude à 14,40 il s'écrase sur
une colline à 500 mètres de la piste pas
un seul survivant des débris de
l'appareil ont été projetés à 200 mètres
du point d'impact une enquête a été
ouverte
nous venons de recevoir une dépêche nous
annonçant que bouni celui qu'on appelait
le forcené de besançon vient d'être
arrêté vous savez que bou nice était
enfermé dans son appartement avec ses
deux enfants il voulait absolument
connaître sa belle-mère ce qui posait un
problème à l'administration puisque sa
femme était pupille de l'assistance
publique et
bouni étaient armées et menaces et tous
ceux qui s'approchaient de la maison les
policiers les journalistes et qu'il
avait même tiré à plusieurs reprises sur
ceux qui s'approchaient ce matin l'un de
ses compatriotes a pu pénétrer chez lui
l'a désarmé il a été immédiatement
conduit au commissariat de police cela
s'est passé à 12h35
revenons-en un maintenant pour quelques
instants une nouvelle politique je vous
rappelle l'une des interventions hier
soir de notre premier ministre monsieur
chaban delmas qui était l'invité de
l'union des jeunes pour le progrès à la
mutualité
répondant à la récente attaque de
monsieur poniatowski secrétaire général
des républicains indépendants contre la
politique du gouvernement monsieur
chaban delmas a notamment déclaré il ne
peut être toléré que des attaques contre
la politique gouvernementale parts des
rangs de la majorité avant que les
instances compétentes de celle ci est eu
à connaître des critiques ou des
objections de certains de ses mains
vous savez que notre président de la
république monsieur georges pompidou
partira le 23 février en voyage officiel
aux états unis monsieur sargent shriver
qui est ambassadeur des états unis en
france était l'invitée de la ville de
nantes et il a évoqué au cours de cette
visite le programme du voyage de
monsieur georges pompidou
seulement vous étiez à washington oui
j'imagine pour préparer la visite du
président pompidou exactement alors je
voudrais savoir dans la conjoncture
actuelle dans quelle ambiance le
président soit reçue aux états unis
prochainement je pense que le président
aurait servi qu à une réception très
chaleureuse à washington notre
gouvernement a fait beaucoup de
préparation pour votre président nous
avons arrangé quelque chose unique
croyez moi pour lui il y a
il y aura un dîner à votre ambassade à
washington est notre présidence unique
s'en
va pour ce dîner c'est la première fois
que qu'il a dit qui a fait une
rendez-vous comme ça aussi votre
président a reçu une invitation
pour donner un discours au devant notre
congrès et les jeux france je pense le
premier
visiteur le premier président de
recevoir une invitation comme ça
202 exemple un autre désir on va se voir
votre président avec une réception
formidable
nous espérons de faire toutes les choses
qui sont possible de rendre la visite
président profite aux états unis
complètement sa décision
d'un volcan en analyse aujourd'hui les
messages qui ont été envoyés par l'union
soviétique aux trois grands à la grande
bretagne à la france
en fait il est par l'union soviétique à
propos du proche-orient et mûri en fait
il s'agit que d'un seul message c'est le
même message en trois exemplaires il
attire l'attention des trois
gouvernements occidentaux sur les
dangers que présente la situation
actuelle dans le proche orient mais il
ne contient cependant c'est ce qu'il
faut préciser aucune menace
d'intervention militaire directe de la
part de l'union soviétique
les deux objectifs de immédiat de la
démarche soviétiques sont d'aider le
président d'acer menacé de l'intérieur
ou acculé à des mesures extrêmes par les
raids israéliens près du caire puis
d'accentuer la pression sur le président
nixon prisonniers ni paix à moscou de la
forte influence de l'opinion
pro-israélienne aux états unis tout
dépend maintenant de la réponse du
président nixon que le président
américain confirme l'envoi des appareils
fantôme à israël et il deviendra
impossible pense-t-on à moscou à l'union
soviétique de refuser les mig 23 que
réclame de son côté le président d'acer
sous peine bien entendu d'être accusé de
passivité par ces aléas qu'est ce qu'il
se passe aujourd'hui lui aujourd'hui on
pourrait presque dire pas grand chose
deux avions égyptiens auraient attaqué
ce matin une position israélienne située
près du canal de suez cela c'est la
version de tel aviv le porte-parole
israélien précisé que cette attaque
n'aurait fait ni victime ni dégâts du
côté israélien il faut bien entendu
attendre la version du caire ne verra
peut être autre chose ce matin à
nanterre s'est ouvert le 19e congrès du
parti communiste
oui c'est ouvert à 9h50
dans la salle du palais des sports de
nanterre à nanterre dans la banlieue
parisienne alors dans la salle on voyait
d'un millier de délégués vous les voyez
également parmi lesquels on remarquait
plus de femmes à 10 heures monsieur
georges marchais monté à la tribune pour
présenter le rapport politique qui était
prévu pour une durée d'au moins trois
heures auparavant dans une brève
intervention monsieur jacques duclos
avaient regretté l'absence de monsieur
waldeck rochet éloigné du congrès par
des soins attentifs et prolongée mais ce
qui fait notre force a ajouté monsieur
jacques duclos
c'est l'esprit de responsabilité
individuelle et collective qui nous
anime monsieur roger garaudy de son côté
assiste au congrès du parti communiste
il a pris place à la table réservée à la
section du val de marne de son côté au
nom du bureau national du parti
socialiste unifié monsieur michel rocard
a envoyé un message au congrès du parti
communiste le secrétaire national du ps
lui déclare notamment via notre site un
extrait il me semble que le combat
socialiste d'aujourd'hui ne peut se
réduire à la défense ou à la 9e se
réduire à la défense de la quille ou à
la recherche d'améliorations partiel
toujours précaire il doit retrouver son
caractère offensif son orientation vers
la conquête du pouvoir pour les
travailleurs le marché commun sont
toujours les problèmes du vin qui sont à
l'ordre du jour oui ces problèmes sont
en voie de règlement il ya une entente à
bruxelles le 20 circulera librement à
l'intérieur du marché commun dès le 1er
avril prochain est la conséquence de
cela c'est que les néerlandais qui ne
consommer que
3,8 litres de vin par an pourront
bientôt approché tout du moins c'est ce
que les viticulteurs espère le record
des français des italiens qui en
consomment 115 litres par an et par
personne je pense que les problèmes les
plus délicats qui était à résoudre est
un sujet des problèmes de courage je
crois que de ce côté là tout est réglé
pour le moment tout est réglé l'accord
définitif devrait être signé dans le
courant du mois eh bien vous savez que
les vacances du mardi gras sont
commencés depuis hier soir et des
enfants le savent mieux que personne les
enfants et qui était hier soir avec
leurs parents pour ce grand exode des
familles ce qui nous permet de nous
rendre à la gare de lyon pour voir
comment ça s'est passé
si les vacances du mardi gras vide paris
de ses habitants elle en pis par contre
les gars hier soir gare de lyon soixante
à soixante-dix mille voyageurs skis sur
l'épaule et chaussures en bandoulière
attendaient patiemment le train qui va
les emporter vers les sommets enneigés
pour cela six trains 67 points bas non
partant toutes les cinq minutes été mis
à leur disposition
hier soir
vous avez vos places pour ce soir dans
le train hélas non j'ai loué vaut pas
soi-même pour partir ce soir
combien de temps vous
pour voyager confortablement il fallait
bien sûr réserver ses places longtemps à
l'avant ce malgré le nombre important
des départs 90 pour toute la journée
d'hier quinze mille demandes ont été
refusées
mais pourquoi les parisiens se sont ils
tous donné rendez vous hier soir
n'aurait-il pas pu partir une journée
plus tard et ainsi éviter la cohue
pour que vous partez aujourd'hui c'est
celle ci titre i
vous ne pouvez pas partir une journée
plus tard de manière
j'en profiterai de journée de mai alors
que si on part
il ne faut pas chercher plus loin la
raison de cette affluence dix jours de
vacances c'est court alors pourquoi
perdre une journée à attendre une place
assise
il suffit de regarder le nombre de
personnes qui se trouvaient à la gare de
lyon et dans les trains pour imaginer ce
que cela peut donner aujourd'hui sur les
pistes le même encombrement avec
certainement des besoins de
réglementation oui dont vous avez dans
le téléphérique dans les téléphériques
par exemple c'est exactement comme dans
le métro aux heures de pointe
actuellement cirque il n'y a aucun
dépaysement pour les gens qui vont skier
c'est finalement ils voudraient tout ne
peut même mieux quelles que soient les
réponses qui viennent d'être donnés
trouver un moyen d'étaler sur de ses
vacances d'avoir pour aménager et
transporte bien sûr puis ensuite pour se
retrouver sur des pistes de manière à
pouvoir profiter de ces pistes que font
les français de leur argent et bien il
ya eu des soldes il ya quelques temps
bien sûr mais il ya aussi cette année
aussi des impôts oui mais ce n est pas
un placement pas pour l'est pas pour les
contribuables wade le pense il y a les
tableaux il y a les tapis il y avait les
bijoux mais les tableaux et quel tableau
vous allez
en 1969 la vente des tableaux a doublé
pour quelles raisons le français est il
subitement devenu un amateur d'art ou
est il tout simplement un spéculateur
mais la vente at elle vraiment augmenter
la question a été posée à des
propriétaires de galeries et à des
peintres et tout d'abord monsieur ratier
propriétaire d'une galerie exposants des
tableaux d'artistes vivants et pour la
plupart peu connus
vous dites qu'en 69 la peinture a
augmenté sans s'il voulait la vente des
tableaux a augmenté du double il
convient d'abord de préciser qu'en 68
elles avaient diminué toujours en ce qui
nous concerne au moins du tiers
la spéculation ou disons
l'investissement existe-t-il en matière
de peinture et le cas se présente il
souvent dans une galerie où les
exposants ne sont pas toujours la même
cote que des vents non guen ou des duffy
alors de temps en temps il y à des
clients les spas qui nous posent des
questions d'ordre spéculatif
et en toute honnêteté nous ne pouvons
pas dire à monsieur tel peintre qui vaut
cent mille francs aujourd'hui va en
valoir 300000 je parle en anciens francs
dans deux ans vous comprenez peut-être
que ça se trouvera je n'en sais rien
un cas différent celui d'une galerie
n'exposant que des grosses pièces venant
guen vlaeminck duffy il serait plus
logique dans ce cas précis de penser à
l'investissement monsieur pétrides est
propriétaire
d'abord ya plus d'un match beaucoup plus
tôt mater beaucoup plus tamisée et de
plus en plus de les plus de nombre de
pays va nous acheter chez nous vous
savez quel est le pen français sont le
plus célèbre le but lâche également
d'anciens c'était un placement sûr
évidemment a en même temps sur et puis
ça fait plaisir quand on a deux très
beaux d'abord à son appartement les
tableaux c'est une compagnie n'est ce
pas le deuxième de vol de régates on
parle avec bien maintenant ils sont des
bandas quand déjà georges tableaux aux
millions que ça monte petit à petit sont
bien contents quand même
deux peintres maintenant le premier
monsieur hambourg déjà connu expose son
oeuvre dans des galeries le second
monsieur la file et est indépendant et
pour lui sa galerie c'est son
appartement comment s'est vendu leurs
peintures en 69 le tableau va chez le
marchand de tableaux qui le vend à ce
moment là le tableau vit sa propre
existence en dehors dehors du pain comme
à leurs enfants qui est majeure en
soixante
votre vente de tableaux a doublé
redoublé genou non la question ne sais
pas pourquoi on a parlé de double et je
crois que la peinture français c'est
beaucoup vendus en 69 pour plusieurs
raisons parce qu'en 68 elle s'était
plutôt mal vendu paraît-il
le marché étranger avait été bloqué en
69 les américains le marché américain
qui est un marché très important pour la
peinture française mais surtout des
peintures très important des peintures
très cher quand on peut parler de
doubler c'est on double le prix lors au
double le chiffre des devis ce qu'on a
fait rentrer en france mais peut-être
que les peintres mêmes n'ont pas
spécialement doublé est-ce que vous
pensez que votre enfant votre production
votre vente de tableaux augmenté en 69
je veux pas dire nettement le met
effectivement augmenté et je me suis
aperçu plusieurs fois si vous voulez que
les gens acheter des tableaux
non pas pour spéculer mais parce que il
pensait que ses tableaux à prendre de la
valeur mais c'est peut-être parce que
j'arrive au bout de dix ans de carrière
qui se disent d'affilée la tête sortir
qu'elle est enfin en gros le pourcentage
de cette hausse en plus un pendant qu'il
n'a pas à prendre n'est pas je veux pas
dire deux fois plus mais il ne me vois
plus oui puisque nous parlons c'est à
l'heure des impôts je dois vous rappeler
il n'est pas inutile de le rappeler vous
le savez déjà que vous bénéficiez de 2
jours de plus pour payer votre premier
tiers provisionnel la limite mais plus
au 15 février mai au 17 février quand
même une bonne nouvelle maintenant eh
bien je vous disais tout à l'heure que
les enfants français avaient commencé
depuis hier soir leurs vacances du mardi
gras il ya d'autres enfants dans
d'autres pays qui eux continuent
appareils
le cirque de moscou pense à l'avenir et
prépare la relève de ses vedettes son
école compte 500 élèves 500 élèves qui
chaque jour après 5 heures d'études
s'entraînent pendant deux heures aux
multiples jeux du site
regardez bien ces élèves ils ont pour la
plupart une dizaine d'années aujourd'hui
ils font leurs premières armes mais dans
quelque temps ils feront alors la
réputation du cirque de moscou
et nous voici maintenant sur l'une des
nombreuses surface gelée des états unis
pour un championnat de char à voile sur
patins un championnat qui nous dit on
n'échappe jamais à monsieur omer sedar
cet américain bien tranquille à 64 ans
11 ans de moins que son chat mais ni
l'un ni l'autre ne veut prendre sa
retraite après tout ils ont bien raison
puisqu'ils remportent eux de toutes les
épreuves dans lesquelles ils s'allument
au maire cedar un nom à retenir c'est
vraiment le ben-hur des temps modernes
voilà notre édition de 13h et terminer
si nous avons d'autres informations
d'ici ou après la bourse sur cette
tragédie de la mine de fouquières lez
lens eh bien nous vous les
communiquerons pour l'instant il me
reste qu'à vous souhaiter un bon après
midi